foreign
[Laughter]
shall I begin
hello everyone let me start by
apologizing for the slight cold I have
that's the only thing that's happening
to me these days let me start by
thanking everyone for participating in
the second Summit of democracies for
democracy I should say but more
importantly thank you for the work
you've put in over the last 15 months to
deliver on commitments you made to each
other and to our peoples for the first
summit of from the First Assembly at our
democracy look you know that's the power
of these summits not just to speak
high-minded words and shine a spotlight
in those critical issues but to
Galvanize action and translate to
concrete progress before people around
the world that's how we make democracy
deliver for everyone and here's what I
hope everyone gathered here and everyone
watching around the world takes away
from this Summit it's working it's
working you know when we gathered here
in December of 2021 the sentiment in too
many places around the world was it
democracy's best days were behind us
democracy declined by some measures for
15 consecutive years
but this year we can say there's a
different story to tell thanks to the
commitment thanks to the commitment of
leaders and Global gather today and the
Persistence of people in every region of
the world demanding their rights to be
respected and their voices being heard
we're seeing real indicators and real
indications that we're at a returning
the tide here as I often say we're at an
inflection point in history here when
the decisions we make today are going to
affect the course of our world for the
next several decades for certain we're
going forward from this Summit our job
is to keep building on our progress so
we don't start heading in the wrong
direction again to keep the momentum
going this is a turning point for our
world toward greater Freedom greater
dignity and greater democracy
here in the United States we've
demonstrated that our democracy can
still do big things and deliver
important progress for working Americans
we're bringing down the cost of
Essentials like prescription drugs and
health insurance premiums we're giving
families a little bit more my dad used
to say a little bit more breathing room
we're rebuilding America's
infrastructure driving Innovation and
tackling the climate crisis while all
while creating good union jobs and
investing in communities that too often
have been left behind in the past we're
also demonstrating the resilience of
American democracy during our free fair
and secure elections last fall America's
first national election since January
6th attack on our capital capital voters
resoundingly and roundly rejected the
voices of extremism attacking and
undermining our democracy the right to
vote to have your vote counted is the
threshold of democracy and Liberty
everywhere in the world
and with it anything is possible without
it in my view nothing is possible that's
why earlier this year I was proud to
sign the bipartisan electoral count
Reform Act to ensure American elections
continue to reflect the will of the
American people and protect the peaceful
transfer of power
you know we're going to keep working to
further strengthen protections by
working to pass what we call the John
Lewis voting rights advancement Act and
the freedom to vote act they're just as
further strengthen our democracy it's
not just the United States that's that's
delivering on our commitment and
demonstrating power of the power of
democracy Angola Angola is taking steps
to build an independent Judiciary
creating three new regions three new
Regional courts of appeal which are
going to help process cases more quickly
the the Dominican Republic has
modernized its anti-corruption law to
create more than 100 anti-corruption
offices at local levels Croatia is
implementing a multi-year
anti-corruption plan to increase
government transparency and better
oversee public procurement
and there are many more examples I could
give and I'm not going to take the time
in many other countries for every person
from countries taking the first steps
toward reform to a well-established
democracies of people making real
changes to protect and strengthen their
democracy look
all we know it's not easy it's not this
has never been easy democracy is hard
work the work of democracy is never
finished it's never laid down and that's
it all you have to do is must be
protected constantly we have to
continually renew our commitment
continually strengthen our institutions
root out corruption where we find it
seek to build consensus and reject
political violence give hate and
extremism no Safe Harbor
we have to continue our efforts to
advance the rights and dignity and
empathize the word dignity of all people
including women and girls
you know because wherever women and
girls are under threat democracy peace
and stability are at risk as well
and we can't achieve our goals if we're
leaving more than half the world's
population out of the solution we just
heard from two incredible women who made
an incredible case about regarding
Belarus they're they're not only when
they're leaders they deserve and all
women deserve to be represented moreover
when we advance equality and racial
Justice we're and invest in young people
protect the lgbtq plus uh individuals
our societies are not only fair but
they're stronger and more successful
democracy demands full and equal
participation of all all of our citizens
that's how we unleash the human
potential and put ourselves in the
strongest possible position to take on
the shared challenges and I I emphasize
shared challenges when democracies Stand
Together We reinforce and amplify each
other's efforts to great effect
and we've seen it over and over again
democracy stepping up to lead and to
solve problems together
not just for our own people but for the
world
from our work to coordinate a global
response to the covid-19 pandemic to
strengthen Global Health security so we
have but we're better prepared to
prevent and respond to a future Global
Health threats to our commitment to
raise our Ambitions on climate goals
that we have to preserve our plan and
literally preserve our planet for future
Generations
to making sure parents can feed their
children strengthening food security by
building more sustainable and resilient
Food Systems around the globe
and the the unprecedented Unity the
unprecedented Unity we've seen from
democracies condemning Russia's brutal
war of aggression against Ukraine and
standing in solidarity with the brave
Ukrainian people as they defend their
democracy so today the United States is
building on our enduring commitment to
boost democracy globally at the first
summit of democracy I launched the
presidential Initiative for Democratic
renewal
committed more than 400 million dollars
a shore of transparent and accountable
governance
support for media freedom to fight for
international fighting International
corruption stand with democracy and
Democratic reformers promote technology
that advances democracy defend elections
now working in close cooperation with
the United States Congress we plan to
add another 690 million dollars for new
funding for the presidential initiative
over the next two years and over the
course of three years my Administration
intends to work with Congress to commit
9.5 billion dollars across all our
efforts to advance democracy around the
world we're all safer when that occurs
we're creating a new Bureau for of
democracy and human rights and
governance at usaid to implement many of
these funding commitments to enhance our
support for Democratic initiatives
globally you know one key focus of our
demo our democracy work will be in
making sure that Technologies can
continue to develop they'll continue to
develop that are used to advance
Democratic governance not used to
undermine it as part of this early this
week I signed an executive order here in
the United States to restrict U.S
government's use of commercial spyware
that has been abused to Target
dissonance activists and journalists
around the world including in the United
States
U.S taxpayer dollars should not should
not support companies that are willing
to sell their products to a Abate human
rights and violations and assuming a a
bet human rights violations and I want
to thank those countries who are joining
us this week in committing to regulate
the use of commercial spyware
this effort is one of many many my
Administration is leaning in the digital
space for strengthening tools for
internet freedom to better protecting
activists and journalists from cyber
threats harassment abuse and and and
shaping emergency emerging Technologies
like artificial intelligence so that
they deliver and develop things that are
in line with our values our values
and as you can probably tell
strengthening democracy is a subject
about which I'm somewhat passionate I
believe this is the defining challenge
of our age and today we can say with
pride that the democracies of the world
are getting stronger and not weaker
autocracies of the world are getting
weaker not stronger that's a direct
result of all of us all of us coming
together with confidence in ourselves
and conviction and our cause
governments around the globe
representatives of civil society and
business Democratic activists and trade
unionist people who refuse to stand
silent at attempts to erode their rights
all all of us are making the choice to
be leaders of our world and what our
world needs to make democracy stronger
to keep the torch of Liberty burning for
ourselves and generations to come
we have to keep going and we will
thanks to the Republican Korea for
stepping forward to host the next Summit
of for democracies and we'll sustain
this forum as a driver of progress for
progress and the anchor for our
commitment to one another
so thank you all again for participating
I look forward to all of you each one of
you to hearing from you and I know I'm
not going to turn uh turn this uh over
to the president of Slovakia Madam
president it's all yours
foreign